[Music]
baseball and statistics go way back
almanacs are filled with stories from
games over the last hundred plus years
but answering deep questions intuitively
has been a giant challenge like grand
slam day
[Applause]
[Music]
the mlb has teamed with google cloud to
push what's possible with data on and
off the field and i'm on a mission to
find out just how they've done it
[Applause]
is first to a left-hander and this one
to a wide-open space mccann with a great
diving stop and he hits peterson out his
first play as a first thanks to the data
analytics tools in the cloud answers to
burning questions that fans have are
within reach now so in a single game how
many data points are you actually
tracking an individual game will capture
25 million unique data points there are
2 430 regular season games every year so
that creates unique challenges for us as
we think about how to deliver that to
our customers
what kind of data is needed to decode
the game one of the more powerful things
that has been done with major league
baseball is by marrying the data to the
video with mlb film room now we're
getting to the point where you're
tracking the ball the players multiple
times every second you really need to
have the right instrumentation and then
have the right technologies to help you
process that data and answer the types
of questions you can get with that data
what are you using to process that data
on the field so we actually are using
anthos which is a deployed kubernetes
inside the ballpark so we send the data
from the ballpark anthos kubernetes to
our kubernetes cluster running in google
cloud from there we're able to scale it
out and store it in cloud sql for our
database and read it back into our stats
api we're able to serve it to millions
of fans around the world in real time
[Music]
data in baseball is clearly a beautiful
marriage but i would like to dig deeper
and find out what's under the hood as
the ball is moving can you walk me
through the process of collecting the
data and processing it now as soon as
the pitch is released we have 12 hawkeye
cameras around the stadium tracking
everything about that pitch at 30 frames
per second so that includes about 60
more data points about every single
pitch so we have processors collecting
all this data from hawkeye holding it
into our data center within the ballpark
and we're able to make these
determinations using the raw data at the
end of the season it amounts to about
over 25 terabytes of data so we can't
easily query this data inside the
ballpark so we need a highly scalable
technology such as bigtable to be able
to store this fast and read it back out
fast in order to get it to our consumer
products in real time
bigtable is awesome to use for things
like post tracking data so one new
exciting project that we're working on
is what we're calling field vision this
will be constant stream of host tracking
data throughout the game visible for a
fan on their desktop or their mobile
phone so using our api we're able to
front bigtable with a scalable
technology that we could serve to
millions of fans
how do you process it further to make it
available for the broadcasters and the
apis anytime you watch a game you'll see
this live strike zone over the center of
home plate it's imperative that we're
able to deliver that information to the
broadcast trucks at very low latency so
every night we have a batch job that
runs and we use dataflow as a key
mechanism to make this work we're able
to move data out of bigtable out of
cloud sql into gcs buckets and then from
gcs buckets into bigquery once the data
lands in bigquery we're able to give
that to analysts and share that with all
30 of the clubs
[Music]
[Applause]
how could teams take advantage of all
this data what does it mean to everyday
operations so how do mlb teams actually
use data basically are pulling in data
from the api for everything from
reviewing major league on performance to
player acquisitions to running our
models what do you do with the data
we're ingesting the data from the
various stats api resources that we have
available regular gumbo feeds the pose
data and then we're aggregating it and
basically filtering it down into
actionable information for our personnel
what are some of the tools that you use
to gain the insights um i'm not sure i
want to answer that one
so i'm trying to get john to tell me how
his team is using specific statcast data
to get better players and improve
performance but he wasn't willing to
spill the tea competitive advantage at
all
[Applause]
[Music]
slider in fastball in change up
curveball cartridge in a pear tree it
makes me wonder how can analysts use the
cloud to help tell the whole story of
baseball and what about announcers how
do they consume this data and translate
it to a fan who might not care much
about that underlying data i say this
many times on mlb now this is not math
class this is baseball and it's always
about asking the question that you want
answered in the ball game and how you
find answers now frequently is is in the
data and so when you're looking at this
data what is the type of information
you're looking for it depends whether
i'm looking for an extreme a specific
instance like a longest career home run
or a fastest pitch or whether i'm
looking at something that bans more of a
career that's where i would use any
combination of a website like a baseball
savant band graphs a baseball reference
stack house allows us to measure
everything on the baseball field we can
tell you how fast a pitch was how hard a
ball was hit we can tell you how far a
home run went and those are the things
that i think can really speak to fans
now i get it a massive amount of data
from the field is captured processed and
published as apis to power tools like
savant film room and internal and
external research
data and analytics in the cloud are
powerful tools and it's been amazing
learning how it's applied in the sports
world today i am so excited for the
future of sports data analytics thanks
for joining me on this journey